A photo finishing store charges
customers a rate of
$0.29 per photo to
print pictures.
For new customers, the
store offers a
one-time discount of $3.
Write a function representing
the amount that a new customer
would have to pay to have x
number of photos printed.
So x is the number of
photos printed.
So just a regular customer would
have to pay the number
of photos times $0.29 a photo.
So if we just said, let y be
the amount that a customer
would have to pay, a regular
customer would have to pay x
times $0.29 per photo.
So we'd write 0.29-- we could
put the dollar sign there if
you want-- or 0.29-- we're
assuming everything is
dollars-- x.
That's how much a regular
customer would have to pay.
But they're asking us a first
time, a new customer.
And they say that the new
customer gets a one-time
discount of $3.
So a new customer will
pay this minus $3.
So this right here is pretty
much a simplified version of a
function that would describe
what a new customer would pay.
If you wanted to get fancy,
this is a little bit
inaccurate when the customer
ordered less than 10 photos
because, let's say the customer
orders 10 photos.
Then x is going to be 10 times
$0.29 is $2.90 minus 3 is
negative $0.10.
The customer is not going to
pay negative $0.10, which
would be like the store paying
them $0.10 for them to print
10 photos, the customer's not
going to pay anything.
So what we could do if we wanted
to make this a little
bit fancier, we could say that a
new customer would pay-- and
then we can say that's y, so y
is equal to 0.29x minus 3 if x
is greater than 10, if the
guy or the gal orders
more than 10 photos.
It's 0 otherwise.
Then they don't pay anything.
If it's less than 10 photos,
they pay nothing.
It's not like the store's going
to pay them, because if
you're less than 10, or 10 or
less, actually, then this is
going to become negative and
we don't want a situation
where it's negative.
So they're either going to pay
nothing, but if they get more
than 10 photos, then they're
going to pay based on this
function right there.